I have many Android users
Visual, physical or age-related impairments
Seeing or using the full touch screen
Or from hearing loss that makes it difficult for them to observe
Audio alerts.
I'm Joanna Smith, I want to help you understand
How to take advantage of access considerations
Three basic.
Because some minor changes to your application
It can make it accessible to most users.
Not all Android users can interact with their devices
In a similar manner.
But it is necessary to make sure that your application
Reusable by everyone.
Access to your app can affect
Number of installs, quality reviews for your app,
And how long users will stay with you.
Android makes creating affordable applications easy
Because it gives you already
Application interface turn text to sound, touch feedback, gesture navigation,
Trackball, Navigation Controller.
There are three tests
You should do it before issuing any application
Which will cover most access scenarios.
While there are hundreds of improvements you can make
Turns out to focus on these three
Will do the purpose.
First, provide the user interface components with content specifications
Does not contain visible speech
It is especially important for photo button, picture display,
And the components of the check box, because these elements
Often affect the effectiveness of the application.
So use the Android format
For content specification or setContentDescription system
To provide this information for access services
Of the device, so that they can provide it to the user
To help reduce the flow of your device,
Adjust the content settings for the decorative patterns to the cancel mode.
I recommend using the TalkBack app
To test each component for logical content specifications
So as to avoid any bad surprises in your application.
Second, make sure users can browse the screen systems
Using hardware-based or software controls
Oriented, such as D-pads, track balls, keyboards,
And navigation bookmarks.
You should be confident that your application
He will support all that.
So be sure to test your app.
There are many applications
Which will help you simulate hardware controls,
Such as the Eyes-Free keyboard, be sure
All elements of the microcontroller are accessible and focusable.
When the user can not simply click on the component that is
Interestingly, the importance of the order of each component is evident.
So check your app's logical transformations
Adjust the focus system as needed.
You can control the focus system through elements
Adjust to be focusable or not, clearly indicate
For the item to be traced.
Finally, a permanent review should be provided
Using more than one technique.
Combine audio and secondary review
To support deaf or hearing-impaired people.
For example, an audio alert for a message arrives
Must be accompanied by a notice system,
Feedback feed if available, or other visual signals.
As I said earlier, these three tests
Will make your app generally accessible.
But if you want to drill deeper into the task lists
We have you can review the documentary.
There are many other considerations,
You can even set up display controls and access services
As you wish.
Now I hope that those changes will help your application
On growth. But if you want to see
Other improvements you can make, see the rest
The styles of our Android content development, joined the community
GL Plus for tips
Tricks and help. But most importantly, he continued to create better designs.